si madame la parole est un monsieur
charles de la verpillière
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de l'éducation nationale vous
préparez une nouvelle circulaire sur les
sections d'enseignement général et
professionnel adapté l'essec pas
s'adresser aux élèves en grande
difficulté à la fin de l'école primaire
à dos et un collège
elle offre un parcours adapté et
individualisée à partir de la sixième
les classes ont un effectif restreint
ses élèves et l'enseignement est
dispensé par des professeurs des écoles
spécialisées et des professeurs des
lycées professionnels
en plus de l'enseignement général les
élèves découvrent les métiers sur des
plateaux techniques et effectué des
stages
l'objectif est qu'il intègre avec succès
un enseignement professionnel de type c
ap en fin de troisième l'essec pas
madame la ministre ont fait la preuve de
leur efficacité
or vous voulez que désormais les élèves
en grande difficulté détecté en cm2
commence par intégrer une classe de 6ème
ordinaire à l'entrée au collège
comment madame la ministre les
professeurs de sixième
pourront-ils enseigné à une classe
composée d'élèves présentant des
différences de niveaux considérables
comment dans des classes à 29 suivre les
programmes en s'occupant d'élèves en
grande difficulté sans freiner la
progression des autres
madame la ministre sous le prétexte
d'inclure ces élèves en milieu ordinaire
vous vous apprêtez à les exclure de la
réussite en cassant un système qui
marche pour vous l'égalité en matière
d'éducation c'est la grisaille de
l'uniformité le nivellement par le bas
pour nous c'est la chance offerte à
chaque enfant de donner le meilleur de
lui même de trouver sa voie et sa place
dans la société
madame la ministre allez vous renoncer à
ce projet sûrement idée d'attendre les
conduisit najat vallaud belkacem
ministres éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
de la verpillière la réforme du collège
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
prétendre n'a absolument pas oublier les
segpa
le projet de décret et d'arrêté donc
nous avons beaucoup parlé d'ailleurs les
énonce en des termes très clairs au sein
d'un collège plus inclusif dix projets
dédie ce décret pardon
ce n'est plus un projet au sein d'un
collège plus inclusif l'asec pas bien
identifiés comme structure permet aux
élèves éprouvant des difficultés graves
d'être mieux prises en compte dans le
cadre de leur scolarité
oui les élèves de segpa bénéficieront de
la nouvelle organisation du collège ils
bénéficieront comme tous les autres
collégiens des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire de l'accompagnement
personnalisé pour être mieux suivis avec
un suivi plus individualisé
c'est une structure la segpa qui a toute
sa place dans le traitement de la
difficulté scolaire et de la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire
et si elle a montré son efficacité et je
redis ici mon attachement à cette
structure
elle doit cependant évoluer pour être
tout simplement aussi plus efficace
évolué pour faire en sorte par exemple
que s'opèrent mieux la transition entre
la fin de l'école primaire et le début
du collège en 6e évolué pour garantir le
droit pour chaque élève non seulement
d'être scolarisés dans les mêmes
conditions que les autres mais aussi de
se rapprocher le plus possible des
autres en multipliant les moments où les
élèves en segpa et les élèves n'ont
certes pas se retrouvent ensemble
enfin c'est pour ces raisons que très
prochainement sera publié en effet une
circulaire qui viendra remplacer les
dispositions qui date maintenant de 2009
et qui visera à conforter les moyens et
l'existence des sectes pas à garantir
une meilleure inclusion des élèves au
sein d'
établissements scolaires et à mieux
définir l'orientation et les modalités
d'admission des élèves dans ce secteur
merci madame la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue